hello everybody and looking to a brain
video today I'm going to be doing a bit
of a market analysis for the month of
November since the month is now over I
thought it'd be good to reflect on some
of the changes that happen this month as
well as one question I want to answer is
why are bonds so damn expensive right
now I could see I just bought one for a
3.2 mm but yesterday they were up to 3
point 7 mil which is scarily high might
even be worth it to just cash in some
money for some easy yet in-game cash or
something but I'm gonna have a look at
some updates this month that have
changed some item prices permanently as
well as look at the new market watch
feature on GE tracker and yeah it's get
started so the start of here I'm going
to be hopping on 2g tracker they are
responsible mind and but I do find this
tool extremely useful for doing some
market research like this looking back a
year into historical values to see why
certain items of doing it help satisfy
my curiosity there will be a link in the
description for that so why are old
school bonds so expensive and why have
they been skyrocketing pretty much since
September so clearly there are more
people buying bonds than there are
people actually purchasing bonds that
makes any sense purchasing I mean they
are buying it within real life money in
feeding bonds into the game buying bonds
is you're buying of the gold so maybe I
should say there's not as many people
selling bonds essentially or a couple
reasons why that might be the case one
solid reason why this could be the case
is offering bond discounts when you're
cashing them in for membership so say
when you are in your bond screen in-game
and your redeeming it the same about to
redeem this bond occasionally they will
offer deals in kind of like two four
ones for certain tiers of membership so
instead of maybe five bonds for three
months it's four bonds or even three
bonds on top of that they're offering
the premier club right now which but
life of me I have no idea what
it does I pretty sure it's just a
discount or maybe other times they offer
incentives to get these tiers but I mean
like right now bronze tier you get three
months of membership great a Silver
Chair six months of membership okay and
gold tier 12 months of membership just
kind of like a normal scale so I'm
really sure what this is about but maybe
someone can answer
if you know leave a comment please so
technically on paper that would actually
be less bonds leaving the game because
well you're buying three months
membership and that's only for bonds I
technically you've used the last however
since is a promotion a ton more people
are gonna try to get those bonds in game
to redeem it for the deal which I think
in turn would be actually moving a lot
more of the bonds from the game and
probably less people are infusing the
market with new ones my second guess it
has to do with the run-up to Christmas
pretty much from September to December
is the big consumer month for pretty
much the Christmas holiday if we look at
the price of bonds from last year you
can see that they were actually
extremely high pretty much with their
end now and directly after Christmas
they plummeted down pretty much by a
mill and I think this is probably the
most compelling evidence that bonds will
pretty much be going up all the way till
Christmas as and will probably tank it
right after now another interesting
feature that G's Recker are recently
added is actually the market indexes I
know there's a bunch of different ones
and pretty much what it is is just a
conglomeration of items in a certain
category so it kind of shows you the
overall health of well the market as a
whole or certain item categories just
clicked on one of them and we're looking
at the log index you can see the items
that include San here includes redwoods
use willows teak oak and whatever the
rest of them and for some reason a key
tree logs I don't know why that's in
there so this is really useful for
looking at overall trends of items so
you can see over the last well three
months it's been slowly declining if we
bring it back to a year you can kind of
see that it's been saying pretty even
for pretty much the whole year not a
whole lot of shift in the log category
if we go have a look at runes that
because I know they have fluctuated
quite a bit and tend to do so more than
items like logs this is just the last
quarter alone it's been going way up and
down and up and down and if we have a
look at the last year
runes actually kind of plummeted around
may/june time and they've been kind of
slowly declining ever since if we have a
look at herbes they've been slowly
increasing in price all the way since
April now the top one here is a market
index which is attempting to show the
overall health of the runescape market
has a bunch of different items mainly
highly traded in market items
except for the rune armor set LG not
sure why that's in there we have a look
at the last quarter it looks like things
have actually generally been decreasing
since pretty much September and if we
have a look at the last year it's pretty
even until September actually what do
you guys think about this still kind of
getting used to it but I thought I'd
show because I think it's interesting so
in the month of November we had a couple
of changes to items so I'm have a look
in see if well if they are a permanent
change in price or it's pretty much just
hype now they a slightly buffed the
server time helm not a whole lot and I
think that kind of shows so mid-november
the serpentine helm did get buffed but
beyond a bit of a hype for one day it
has remained the same price no change in
price so it really kind of reflects on
the value of the buff clearly it didn't
do a lot now if we have a look at
theorem staff now technically this buff
was actually done this month the main
price increase happened back in October
because that's when the change was
originally posted we kind of an
interesting post on reddit regarding the
rim staff is one guy who had 10,000 the
room staffs or something and you see my
loop from seven months of posting
over there so this guy bought theorem
stabs for about 50 K each proceeded to
post some reddit about how the room
staff needed to be buff which is totally
valid I don't think that the mod should
ever take into account if someone
happens to have a bill worth of the item
it doesn't really matter it really
should just really come down to if the
item actually needs to be buffed or
what's better for the actual integrity
of the game it doesn't really matter if
this guy happened to have 10,000 a room
staff anyway proceeds to make posts
about it and after that the mods
actually decided to buff the room staff
to make it a one-handed weapon
dramatically increasing the price to I
guess one hundred and seventy KS maybe
what he sold them at so this guy could
have made easily 800 mil off of that
flip which is just completely ridiculous
so in the month of November the prices
continue to increase until the actual
update came peaking about 215 K and now
it is down to about 100 K again and last
time I'm just gonna quickly have a look
at the band o Scott so we're guess I
know this wasn't technically in November
well wasn't in November at all no
technicalities around it but we gonna
have a look at it quickly the band of
gods were actually got its special
attack reduced to 50% so now you can
actually use it twice this actually had
a direct massive increase on
Bannos gods who are peaking at seven mil
it's almost four times the amount that's
almost an increase of 400% anyway guys
that's about it I just wanted to have a
look at some of the market changes this
month if you do enjoy videos like this
don't forget to toss the video like I
always appreciate it if you have any
topics you want me to go over for next
time when I do something like this I
definitely leave a comment down below
alright thanks for watching see you next
video